terre bertrand legrand médecins
généralistes bonsoir à vous merci d'être
en direct avec nous ce soir sur arte
france alors la stratégie du
gouvernement de confier progressivement
est ce qu'elle est efficace l'on risque
de courir après le virus comme on a
couru après virus depuis le mois de
janvier on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la
france est exactement au même niveau que
le brésil qui est tant décrié en termes
d'incidence
nous on constate dans les départements
comme le mien qui sont aujourd'hui a mis
en vigilance que les réanimateurs sont
complètement submergées et que nous
faisons des transferts de patients et on
constate ça a même au moment où dans mon
propre cabinet je ne suis pas encore au
niveau de ce que j'avais connu en
septembre de débordements ce qui veut
dire qu'on n'est pas du tout sur une
femme vague on est sur un début de
vagues avec une réanimation qui commence
à être engorgé et la ville qui commence
tout simplement à travailler énormément
sur les personnes positives donc
effectivement extrêmement inquiétant est
probablement lié une virulence plus
importantes du des variants ça veut dire
qu'on risque un scénario identique à ce
que l'on a connu l'année dernière à la
même période
ce qui est malheureux effectivement
c'est que nous n'avons toujours pas plus
de lits de réanimation alors on allait
les lits de réanimation qu'il fallait
armés
et il n'avait pas besoin de respirateurs
donc il suffisait de changer un certain
nombre de prises d'oxygène ça n'a pas
été fait pendant un an
on essaye de replâtrer tant bien que mal
à nouveau pour une troisième fois
on a vraiment l'impression je pense à
l'hôpital mes collègues de l'hôpital des
hôpitaux ont l'impression qu'on ne tire
jamais les enseignements de ce qui s'est
passé avant et on anticipe jamais mais
après même si on se place en amont au
niveau de la ville on isole même pas le
malade suffisamment longtemps pour
éviter la contagion on est toujours sur
des théories fumeuses dès d'isolement
qu'ils sont insuffisants ou on a des
patients qui sont très contagieux au
delà du 10e jour donc ça fait de tout ça
on ne tirait strictement aucune leçon
jusqu'à jusqu'au campagne de
communication sur la vaccination ou
derrière nous nous recevons strictement
aucun vaccin et où aujourd'hui même j'ai
dû annuler des 35 6 nations prévue
dimanche soir donc le cc voilà l'espoir
de sortir de cette crise ça reste quand
même à la campagne de vaccination qui
est sous le feu des critiques jugées
trop lente ou au niveau européen quels
sont les espoirs finalement d'arriver au
bout de cette campagne de vaccination
parce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est
que on nous promet en communication
l'augmentation du nombre de bras et on
nous le vend comme on nous avait promis
les commandes de masques qui ne sont pas
arrivés que trop tard et bien des
manières en fait là ce qui manque c'est
pas des bras ce qui manque c'est des
doses faut comprendre que les médecins
généralistes n'ont jamais été livrés de
vraiment un grand d'une grande quantité
de doses que les centres de vaccination
sont d'excellents centres où on peut
passer des politiques pour venir montrer
que l'on fait de la vaccination
alors on propose un chiffre mais jamais
ces centres de vaccination n'égaleront
la puissance de feu des médecins
généralistes donc le vrai problème c'est
le nombre de doses et aujourd'hui on est
obligé de sélectionner nos patients et
on se rend compte que pour des raisons
j'irai politique ou d'affichage de
communication toute cette priorisation
et demi à la poubelle et l'ensemble du
travail qui a été fait par les médecins
généralistes et mis à la poubelle
on nous on est pris à défaut c'est à
dire qu'on ne nous valide des commandes
on reçoit pas la commande on nous promet
qu'on peut commander
on ne peut pas commander on n'a pas ce
qu'il faut on n'a pas les je ne sais pas
vous dire pourquoi on n'a pas ça on en
est à un stade aussi stupide que je peux
aller chercher des vaccins pfizer dans
un centre de vaccination pour vacciner
quelqu'un à domicile mais techniquement
on m'oppose le fait de pouvoir aller
chercher dans le même centre de
vaccination des flacons pour vacciner en
masse mais patients si vous voulez
cesser totalement inacceptable il n'y a
plus aucune raison qui empêche
aujourd'hui un médecins généralistes de
vacciner avec n'importe lequel des
vaccins à part à la volonté politique
d'afficher un grand nombre de
vaccination dans un centre mais ça
n'arrive à rien c'est de la politique de
communication on vous suit aussi sur
twitter bertrand legrand vous avez
proposé un adage au gouvernement
français vous dites les promesses de
livraison ne valent que pour les
britanniques qui savent signets et
négocier des contrats
là encore il faut pointer du doigt ce
qui a été menée jusqu'à présent au
niveau européen hoballah je pense que
très clairement qui peut encore nier le
fait que la campagne de vaccination se
passe mal que les commandes se sont mal
passées et que l'europe est moins bien
livré que n'importe quel autre pays je
sois énormément de patients issus du
maghreb
ils sont mieux vacciner au maghreb qui
en france font sécher sont eux que je
joue comme on peut comment on peut vivre
ça et se pointer sur un plateau de
télévision en disant qu'on a tous bien
fait comme il faut enfin moi je trouve
ça a baissé c'est ubuesque cette
communication
voilà on parlait du taux d'incidence
tout à l'heure il est très inquiétant
chez les jeunes dans les écoles aussi et
la fermeture ou non des écoles justement
fait débat pour l'instant les classes
restent ouvertes c'est la stratégie qui
est défendue par l'exécutif et le
gouvernement selon vous est ce que c'est
une bonne décision
à écouter on a un gouvernement qui co et
qui prend conscience qu effectivement là
que l'infection à l'intérieur à la
contagion à l'intérieur d'une école est
problématique
elle voit dès que des départements qui
sont avec une incidence importante où
elle se dit bah tiens on va faire on va
anticiper on va fermer les cartes les
classes et dans les autres départements
dont je vous le rappelle quand même
dépasser tous les seuils d'alert
antérieures c'est pas parce qu'on bouge
le seuil d alerte que ce seuil d alerte
n'existait pas avant
et là on va les faits se diffuser le
vecteur un des vecteurs c'est l'école
aujourd'hui on le sait pendant très
longtemps qu'on ne le savait pas au
début des flammes à l'aide de l'est de
l'épidémie on ne le savait pas
aujourd'hui on sait que l'école est un
vecteur
donc il ya un moment donné
s'il faut faire de la place parce qu'on
va avoir deux à quatre semaines
difficiles il faut aussi en passer par
la fermeture des écoles
le conseil scientifique l'a recommandé
le politique ne le fais pas moi je veux
bien qu'on négocie mais on négocie pas
en fait avec un virus donc ce qui va se
passer c'est que vous allez avoir des
images de personnes dans les dans les
couloirs des réanimations parce que
c'est ça qui nous attend merci beaucoup
à vous bertrand legrand je rappelle que
vous êtes un médecin généraliste